this morning they were still fighting
the blaze at the zaparilla nuclear plant
the fire missed the reactors themselves
but this latest video shows just how
close the shelling came
rounds punching holes through the
walkway running through the nuclear
complex just meters from the reactors
themselves
a potentially grave nuclear incident was
avoided but it's still a tragedy of a
different kind officials had warned of
the nuclear risks since this invasion
began
warnings that have been ignored we of
course are fortunate that there was no
release of radiation but
it is obvious that when we all agree on
these principles
words must mean something
and we have to act in consequence there
are six reactors at the zaparisia
complex each containing 60 tons of
uranium fuel fortunately the part of the
complex that caught fire was this
training facility a few hundred meters
from the reactors themselves at the time
of the incident only this reactor number
four was operating the other units had
already been shut down as precaution
making them much safer were they to be
damaged
in addition to zaparisia in the east
there are three other nuclear complexes
in ukraine rivner
helmanitzki and south ukraine nuclear
power plant there's concern about this
facility too given the expected russian
advance on odessa to the south
what's the risk the concern of course is
a chernobyl style nuclear accident the
worst in the industry's history
but all ukraine's current reactors are
of the same vver model it's a design
that's inherently safer than chernobyl
they have a thick steel pressure vessel
around the reactor and a concrete
containment building protecting the
entire structure but they're not
designed to withstand warfare modern
reactors are actually very strong and
robust and before that time they do have
containment and they do have some
structural integrity but
i mean whether they've been designed
with projectiles and missiles in mind i
think that's probably not the case
experts believe the worst case scenario
for a reactor failure in ukraine would
be something similar to the fukushima
disaster in japan
prompt evacuation meant no known
fatalities linked to radiation there
but a nuclear emergency during a
conflict already as brutal as this
carries untold risk
the fact that ukraine's nuclear sites
are even in the firing line says much
about the invading army's attitude
towards the harm they might cause
tom clark sky news